Usually we call nations by just one or two names or an abbreviation of these
names or some other variation,
but it's not very common that we encounter.
Are there other names do United States of America,
the USA,
America,
the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland,
the UK,
Great Britain,
the Russian Federation or just Russia,
et Cetera,
but some countries have less or none names that have a poetic or historical ring
to them.
What can we call these other countries to begin?
Australia is older.
Name was new Holland from the Dentrix for Abo Tasman who named Tasmania.
Number two on the list,
the natives of Brazil give their country the name Hindle Rama.
Before Portuguese colonization though the Portuguese originally called the Land
Tara,
the Santa Cruz,
the land of the Holy Cross,
China may be called [inaudible],
which is an older European name for the nation in the Chinese language and
nation is known as Chung Gore Ethiopia.
Ethiopia's name comes from the Greek [inaudible] referring to all the land south
of Egypt,
but the former name for the land is Ibus,
the from the Arabic word for the people of the region.
France has been referred to as God by the name of the Roman province established
by Julius Caesar.
Often jokingly,
the country's called legs lagoon,
referring to it's hexagon shaped
Greece is officially called the Hellenic Republic and maybe referred to as such
or in short ls.
The Hungarians maybe referred to you by the more proper names,
the Meyers and there may she maybe called Maya Roars.
Sac India.
His name in Hindi is far rod and in Sanskrit it's Arya Varta.
Hindustan is also an unofficial name for the country.
Iran only became Iran in the 1930s for all of history.
Before that it was referred to as Persia.
The country is also sometimes called farce.
Number 10 the Romans gave Ireland the name,
he battered me,
ah,
or Hibernia because of it's called climate and in the eyes of the Romans,
lack of the light of civilization.
The name is still used in legal and professional matters revolving around
Ireland.
The Japanese call their country neon.
Alternatively Nippon and Yamato was the name of classical Japan.
The official name from Mexico is the status you need those Mexicanos or the Eum,
the United Mexican states I'll tear or I was a name given to New Zealand by the
native Maori tribes and the name is still sometimes used Russia,
maybe called Reus and was referred to as great Russia in the past which like
Great Britain is a geographical term.
The name is Zenia was used by South Africans fighting the apartheid as a name
for their nation.
The name dates back to the Romans referring to the land south of Kenya as of
course the Romans were not aware of the greater south of Africa.
The United Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern Ireland is called Britain,
Great Britain and the UK and so forth.
It is also known as Albion which has a Latinized name of the Scottish wherever
the land as for the countries inside England,
maybe called Anglia or Anglia Scotland to be called Alba or Caledonia and Kimra
is another name for Wales.
United States of America is called the United States,
the USA.
And America,
which is confusing because America is also the name of two continents.
It's creators proposing names,
Columbia,
Apalasia,
Allegheny,
and even free Donia upon its creation.
Other names include variations of the word that use Sonia,
and that's all I have for you today.
For more videos on nations,
their histories,
and much more,
I would invite you to subscribe and check out my channel.
Thank you for watching.